my days are measured by how much battery
I have left in this meter but too often
my phone is out of juice before I am and
you know who I blame for it Apple and
their fin phones into the woods but
today the company is finally admitting
that heavy iPhone 6 and 6s users like me
could use the extra juice Apple's $100
smart battery case is like a Mophie or
the dozens of other battery cases out
there but there's one big difference
it feels very Apple unlike those
unsightly plastic cases that attach in
two pieces this feels like apples wrap
around Silicon case except with a
protruding awkward battery on the back
yeah it looks like the case is about to
give birth to a rectangular alien oh and
don't get the white version unless you
plan to spend your days cleaning it
still I'll take it over all these ugly
messes and like the best battery cases
it will protect the phone in a fall plus
while other cases require a microUSB
charging cable Apple obviously uses its
lightning cable it also integrates right
into iOS instead of a blinking LED light
to tell you how much you have left in
the case it says right on the screen
okay okay so how much extra power will
you actually get from this protruding
battery it charged my dead iPhone up to
83 percent in my battery test the whole
package lasted 13 hours and in
real-world use I had plenty of juice
left over at the end of the day plus
Apple's case intelligently decides when
to charge the phone there's no on/off
switch like the others there are bigger
and cheaper cases that will give you way
more juice though for instance this
$80 tilt energy case has a battery
that's twice the size of Apple's it
charged my dead iPhone up to a hundred
percent and then again up to 50 the tilt
made free you from the wall plug a
little bit longer but I'm going with the
smart case for its iPhone integration
and design sure I wish the iPhone simply
just had a bigger battery inside but at
least Apple is finally doing something
to ease the
ring